and welcome to this video playing climb
512 this cube on this Cuba oh this is
something American like all I do Russ or
something thailand who i had gotten this
one right before I screwed this up
terribly okay I'm the Queens gambit
let's see I wanted to go here and I lost
30 seconds due to the flack miss Reed or
miss miss gasp okay let's play the note
ball at some leading to shower play I
hope I can still remember some of that i
played this years ago on a regular basis
specialty too I don't think yeah b5 now
it's not so great to play night of 60
III no not at all it's not it's just
filled shattering interesting can I go
b5 now or is this is this insane they
are come on let's let's develop stuff I
can also place you 5m the one drawback
of whites position is that he not easily
retained or against the porn here maybe
with 95 at some stage but it's not easy
to do really playing this first and then
I Bishop c5 it could have gone Bishop c5
as well because 95 is meant by Bishop f2
but why not 96 not a bit but way to play
and taking a c5 next yeah there's no
easy way to get c4 back maybe I'm young
muthiya exactly move the bishop and
now then try to play night md to
something like that um yeah I don't know
I can just take Queen a5 is probably
nonsense now i'm just taking this my not
okay at least not much choice you can
try it 94 and then regain the porno
doesn't yeah i don't know i wonder if i
should play a 5v5 be sure b6 yeah come
on it develops the bishop and lend some
extra protection to the pawn 94 I'm
dropping back to have six I must of
course protected here be shown here and
I have even night a 52 m to hold on to
the pawn and I will do that it's putting
the night on the side of the bot but
it's it's very important to spawn not
giving it away easily
now I don't really see him regaining it
yeah it's night b3 something worth
considering I don't don't know and I
just let's just get our pieces into play
look here and if you move the a1 look I
have a 6b five also
the rukon see to allow smooth of the
knight on f3 and you can go nitey you
one now for example all night h4 okay
yeah what we should be for as possible
but ok let's just prepare everything
some King to e7 you should be 40 what is
this ok we wants to play Bishop everyone
now understand so ok let's let some
introduce b5 into this position and I
can also always play Bishop before it's
not I am to fi but the Nidal f5 is not
really doing much plus there's the pin
yeah 93 and I to be three rice is
terribly pinned now yeah this loses the
night actually push up g for now and
turn and dad then that's it he will lose
one of those pieces
and sometimes it happens in them in
those Catalan type of positions where
black gets the c-4 porn and you simply
never gain it to regain it determine
white resins it's of course not
necessary thing but it might happen if
you just don't play it right you never
see the pawn returning to you um if we
look at this position at that I think
that black is just fine here he has a
hard time to regain the porn really i
don't i don't see a way at the moment
the bishop on g2 is the natural piece to
regain it f1 c4 but it's already
fianchetto wood and this means the pawn
is hard too hard to get and this this
operation i think leaves is black almost
winning I don't I don't see why
defending this position anymore I have
two bishops I have the center with e5
coming and that keep the pawn and this
is just too much he won't regain it this
is no problem at all getting the night
on a five you know tears it's basically
technical task here he loses even more
material this will lead to a loss of a
piece at least many many problems and
here i can take on d to simply that's it
yeah this was some simply not a great
opening I I think this is all very well
known i think here probably g3 is not
not very good just III and get the palm
back I will probably play c5 something
like that and it's just relatively a
normal-looking position alright thanks
for watching